[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wales
heute gibt es einen richtig leckeren
mama kuren mit haselnüssen und formen
wären da ist wirklich super saftig ganz
einfach in der herstellung und das
einzige was ihr braucht müsst ist dass
die zutaten alle zimmer warum sind dann
habt ihr nämlich den perfekten mama
kochen ja willst du denn gleich
probieren mit bisschen milch lag ja aber
jetzt zuerst einmal zeige ich euch mal
die zutaten die wird dafür benötigt
mit mama corinne brauche ich 250 gramm
weiche butter 200 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt und salz 14 war mayer
250 milliliter lauwarme milch den abrieb
einer unbehandelten zitrone 250 gramm
mehl drei teelöffel backpulver das ist
ein päckchen 250 gramm gemahlene
haselnüsse und dann noch wird in choco
teig also für die schoko version hier 40
gramm packung 40 milliliter milch rund
200 gramm bern nämlich zuerst einmal die
zimmer warme butter und da ist wirklich
wichtig dass die zimmertemperatur hat
und dass auch die eier zimmertemperatur
haben also beide zutaten rechtzeitig aus
dem kühlschrank rausnehmen
da kommt jetzt der zucker mit salz und
vanille schüssel immer dann können sich
die vanille sahne nur von 10 verteilen
und jetzt wird die butter zucker
mischung einfach nur etwa vier bis fünf
minuten richtig cremig berührt
[Musik]
sobald die butter zucker masse dann
richtig cremig ist kommt jetzt ein ei
nach dem anderen dazu und da ist
wirklich ganz wichtig dass jedes ei für
etwa eine minute eingeführt wird damit
es sich gut mit der butter masse
vermengt
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich noch den zitronenschalen
abrieb dazu das macht den maurer kuchen
immer extrem frisch
jetzt kommt ein schluck milch schreien
und dann kann ich auch schon mehl mit
backpulver dazu sieht
und die zutaten jetzt ganz vorsichtig
und ganz langsam einrühren
jetzt kommt hier noch die restliche
milch langsam dazu dann noch die haare
[Musik]
und da ist wichtig dass man das meer so
noch ganz kurz ein rot dann wird der
mama kuchen nämlich schön locker so viel
datei gibt auf und jetzt werde ich einen
teil dunkle einfärben
das heißt kakaopulver in der schüssel
die milch dazu wer möchte geht jetzt
noch ein bisschen rum dazu und lässt den
tag einfach nur ein bisschen mehr
aufgehen wenn es zu fest ist einfach
noch mal ein bisschen milch dazu oder um
das eine cremige masse entsteht
und jetzt kann ich da ungefähr ein
drittel vom teig dazugeben und kurz ende
hören
[Musik]
und ich mag den mama koren jetzt in
einer katzen phorms manchmal wirklich
super hübsch aussieht die fertig jetzt
vorher mit back trends und wer benötigt
kann sie auch noch auswählen
es geht hier die hälfte vom hellen tag
rein kurz bestreiten
da kommen jetzt ein paar bomben drauf
[Musik]
damit der teig
bestreichen und mit brombeeren bedecken
[Musik]
und der restliche helle tag
und wer möchte kann jetzt mit gabel
nehmen und hier einfach so ein paar
bälle wurden spiralen ziehen dann
vermischen sich die beiden tage nämlich
und da kommen jetzt noch mal glaube nein
um bernd rauw warum werden für ein
aufatmen
so kann das jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen und kann gebacken werden
[Musik]
nach dem backen habe ich den kugeln
abkühlen lassen aus der form genommen
und noch mit süßem schnee bestreut das
ist der feine puderzucker der nicht
schmilzt so geht's durch die zwei
probieren
ok ok tyler herr müller
einmal noch einen teller bitte dahin und
ich finde man halt einfach schön wenig
ist lass dich wäre deshalb möchte also
ich find's toll kuchen immer lecker mit
einem glas mensch ihr bestimmt auch oder
und vor allem mit der mama kuchen also
wenn es überhaupt mal zwei drei tage
durchhält und noch da ist dann ziemlich
den immer und gießen und drüber und dann
öffentlich sowie hand voll lecker lecker
das freut mich sogar ein problem könnten
ja sagen ja gelb und er hat immer ein
anderes muster da drinnen trägt man nie
mehr wieder so hin wisse zwar weil immer
ist fünfter anders ja richtig tolle
einfacher kuchen gerne auch mal für
einen sonntag zum beispiel und falls ihr
das rezept sucht dann findet ihr es auf
meinem blog auch sellings - blog.de ich
wünsche euch viel spaß und nach backen
können wir jetzt auch ein glas milch
vielleicht aber auch cappuccino
das weiß ich noch nicht überlege ich mir
noch und dann ein stückchen mauer
konkrete schnittig die ja bis zur
nächsten mal wenn man das anfangs stück
immer wieder so da dran legt und dann
weiter schneidet dann bleibt auch immer
schön saftig mal stand trocknet
schneller kommt auch im mittelstand
[Musik]